I ride I seize the gravity waves of the
Big Bang itself and ride the universe
fight MCOs a glimpse too fast to be
perceived by you in sight a slingshot to
expend in cosmos swerve into a firing of
a file space as they filed to coalesce
I see Leviathan taking its last breath
cursing in the language of ancient gods
convulses
it's very entrails hardening into
bizarre crystal formations
like witness a new realm being born
shattered mirror images were playing the
same cosmic contest over
I see the masters of this realm
flamboyant New Gods collecting mortal
lives for their own vanity and
entertainment
I see many champions rise and fall in
their name
I see hero fight hero brother fight
brother
trapped in an endless spiral of violence
as old as time itself
but I also witnessed the seeds of
rebellious fellowship
they spread out some heroic sacrifice of
defiant hope
and it is for hope that I break the
barriers of space and time it is for
hope that I searched the four corners of
the battlefield it is for hope that I
ride
[Music]
a long time ago I made a promise to my
friends no matter how long it takes or
how far I have to travel I will fulfill
that promise
I will find them and bring them back
home
thus Spoke the Silver Surfer
you